sudeep is a wealthy and influential man
who has everything one could ask for all
the cops in the area work for him while
all the gangsters fear his presence
sudeep has no problems seducing women
either however there is one Beast that
gives him sleepless nights and makes him
pee his pants a fly wherever sudeep goes
and whatever he does the fly is always
after him in one instance the menacing
insect even drives a needle straight
into his eyes following this the movie
flashes back to a month earlier where
sudeep is showcasing his impeccable
shooting skills at a training center his
every shot is On Target and his
performance leaves everyone awestruck as
sudeep finishes his practice session his
business partner and close friend Aditya
approaches him with some urgent news
about an upcoming business meeting
however sudeep seems uninterested and
pays no heed to aditya's words instead
he focuses his attention on a woman and
starts training her seductively
following this we are introduced to
Bindu a beautiful Mini picture artist
who spends most of her time creating
jewelry and other items at present she
is busy with her work the power suddenly
goes out this leaves her in complete
darkness so she decides to finish her
task using the faint glow of the
Moonlight meanwhile bindu's neighbor
Nani who has an intense crush on her
keeps staring at her through the window
he is adamant on making her fall in love
with him this time Nani tries to help
bendu by constructing a makeshift light
bulb out of a Torchlight and aluminum
sheet the plan works and she is able to
finish her artwork however instead of
thanking Nani for his efforts bendu
straightaway closes the window and goes
to sleep the following day she deep
throws a lavish party to celebrate his
business's third anniversary several
wealthy people are in attendance and
among them is a client who was
previously deemed very hard to please
but to everyone's surprise the client
hands sudeep his file agreeing to do
business with him this shocks edithia as
he had always believed the client would
never shake hands with them but little
did he know that the clients wife is
actually the same lady whom sudeep had
seduced back at the weapons training
center after the party the business
partners head to a pub to celebrate
their accomplishments with a drink as
they Converse we learned that CDP didn't
earn his riches but they in fact came
from his late wife whom he murdered a
few years back in the next scene we get
to know that Bindu also runs project 551
a non-profit organization that supports
children's education the NGO is planning
to get new books for the children but is
held back because of financial
difficulties just then a lady suggests
spindu set up a meeting with sudeep
since his company is looking to fund an
NGO taking the advice Bindu visits
sudeep in his office where he is
instantly Smitten by her beauty bendu
explains about her ngo's activities but
sudeep is too busy gazing at her then
out of nowhere he hands her a massive
check of 1.5 million rupees which
surprises her the latter is a bit
hesitant at first as she has never
received a donation of such stature but
after a bit of contemplating she takes
it and says thank you soon they deliver
books and accessories to underprivileged
children in their Community sudeep who
is still awestruck by her beauty takes
this opportunity to ask her out bendu
can't refuse him after the effort he has
shown so she agrees she had no problem
cold shouldering that dork with the
flashlight though later at a fancy
restaurant as they are about to order
food Bindu suddenly receives a text from
Nani who compliments her appearance
knowing that he is somewhere near she
looks around and notices him standing on
the opposite side of the restaurant
observing her this time however even
Bindu is fascinated by his charm and
persistence as she keeps looking at him
sudeep becomes envious of Nani after the
meal as sudeep is driving Bindu home she
makes him pull over and says that she
has to shop for groceries slightly
hesitant he lets her go but follows her
secretly then he finds her with Nani and
gets dejected at the site this is
because he has never had a lady turn him
down before hence he may makes it his
mission to separate the two one night
bendu works late and is too afraid to
return home alone as a result she sends
Nani a blank text hoping that he would
interpret it as a sign and come to her
he receives the text and as expected
hurries over the two then chat all the
way home sharing random stories and
jokes unfortunately just as Bindu enters
her apartment a white vehicle arrives at
the scene and abducts Nani they are
gangsters sent by sudeep to take Nani
out of bindu's life they drag him to a
vacant home and beat him up mercilessly
sudeep also appears and starts punching
him Nani warns that anyone who attempts
to hurt Bindu would die by his hands
sadly this only infuriates sudeep so he
finishes off the innocent man the next
second Bindu calls Nani to express her
feelings for him but it's too late their
love story has ended before it even
began starting to wonder what the hell
this movie has to do with a fly with
needles after the goons leave though
something strange happens Nani's body
begins glowing blue and the light
transfers to a nearby fly's egg oh okay
the next morning Nani's corpse is found
in the middle of the road and the
corrupt cops claim that it was an
accident bendu also arrives at the scene
and becomes devastated to see his body
being hauled away in an ambulance after
10 days the egg that was touched by the
unusual light finally hatches and out
comes a tiny fly in a shocking twist it
turns out that this fly is none other
than Nani himself who has come back to
seek revenge on his attackers initially
Nani has no memory of the past existence
and tries to fly away but fails
miserably as his wings are
underdeveloped when he eventually
spreads his wings and soars into the air
he is almost drowned by pouring water
Nani then goes about his new existence
astonished by the floating Bubbles and
children running around he begins to
play with the Bubbles as they float
popping them Nani falls on a half-eaten
Apple after becoming trapped on a
cricket ball then a bird starts pursuing
him 4 forcing him to enter a house to
save himself there he is accidentally
drowned in a cup of water by a person
Nani peeks out and notices its sudeep
who is holding the glass of water and in
that instant Nani's memories come
flooding back and he realizes the full
extent of his tragic fate I'm gonna have
to piss this guy off enraged he
immediately leaps out of the cop and
Strikes his attacker however he comes to
his senses when he realizes that his
body has changed and he can't physically
hurt humans after being swatted away by
sudeep he recalls Bindu and hurries over
to her home when he finally sees her
after all these weeks he becomes
emotional Nani tries his best to get
noticed by her but fails because of his
tiny stature at the moment Bindu is
chatting with her sister mentioning how
much Nani meant to her hearing this the
fly gets even more motivated to gain her
attention later when Bindu is at her
workplace sudeep arrives to see her he
expresses his fake sympathy at Nani's
passing and tries getting close to her
but just then the fly arrives and gets
into his ear chasing him away even in
his present State Nani is adamant on
protecting the love of his life in the
next scene sudeep enters a wooden steam
bath and tries to relax but the fly
again enters his ears and disturbs him
as he struggles he almost ends up
getting impaled by a sharp shower handle
when the situation becomes very annoying
sudeep dashes outside totally naky and
attempts to kill the fly he doesn't
succeed in doing so but what he does
succeed in is making a mockery of
himself in front of his professional
colleagues and clients later in his
office sudeep invites Bindu to accompany
him to Delhi for an important business
meeting hearing this the fly distracts
sudeep from sleeping soundly at night in
order to prevent them from leaving
several hours pass by but sudeep is so
Disturbed that he cannot even close his
eyes it is only when he wraps his head
with the bed sheet then he falls asleep
but the very next minute he gets a call
from Bindu informing him that they must
board the plane in 30 minutes they rush
to the airport but Nani followed them
too at first the fly annoys the traffic
officer causing him to swing his hands
in odd ways and cause a traffic block
sudeep hurriedly changes cars hoping to
get away from the Demonic insect but he
has soon attacked in the eyes leading to
a deadly accident the fly then writes I
will kill you
on the windshield with dust while sudeep
watches helplessly from the back seat of
the car after sudeep is rescued he
becomes paranoid over the killer fly so
he carries a fly spray with him
everywhere he goes seeing his actions
others around him start calling him
delusional just then Bindu arrives to
meet sudeep when Nani notices the two
together he immediately flies to a taxi
deep but is shockingly sprayed by Bindu
he lands on a shrub after falling out of
the window just when it appears as if
the fly is going to die the water
sprinkler starts washing away the poison
from his body and thus saving his life
after the terrifying incident with the
fly sudeep seeks the advice of an
entomologist to understand whether flies
are capable of seeking Revenge however
the expert dismisses his concerns as
mere hallucinations advising him to calm
down however sudeep remains unconvinced
and travels to The Dumping area where
his car was towed after the accident
there he encounters a strange guy who
informs him that fire will soon consume
his fortune but despite the ominous
warning sudeep continues his search for
any clues that could confirm his
suspicion as he sifts through the debris
he finally comes across a shattered
piece of glass with the word kill
crudely scrawled on it with this
sudeep's worst fears are confirmed and
he is now certain that the fly is trying
to kill him the next day Nani notices
Bindu sobbing remembering his death
sensing the opportunity he writes a
message with her Teardrops on the table
when Bindu finally reads it she is
completely taken aback she cradles the
fly in her palm and inquires whether he
is Nani the latter confirms his rebirth
with a nod of his head yes oh that's me
Nani then reveals everything about his
death and also informs Bindu that sudeep
did all of this just to get close to her
hearing this Bindu is devastated she
then agrees to assist Nani in taking
down sudeep help me kill him please
using her sculpting skills Bindu
constructs tiny spectacles for the fly
to protect him from Talent chemicals
meanwhile a paranoid sudeep instructs
his bodyguards to kill the fly but
neither of them succeed he also quickly
discovers that chemicals are ineffective
against the fly sudeep tries everything
from fly poison to fly swatters but none
of them work over the course of the next
few days Nani goes on a rampage against
sudeep he sets fire to his bed forces
him to drink fly poison and refuses to
let him fall asleep while the small
pranks annoys you deep a lot it is not
enough to kill him as a result Nani
plans to load gunpowder into a
functional Cannon replica and fire it at
the appropriate time to kill sudeep
bendu spends the next few days filling a
small bucket with gunpowder for Nani
which he then pours into the cannon this
is gonna get bindi's going to jail they
continue this procedure until the cannon
is entirely filled but the scheme fails
when a guy inserts tissue paper into the
muzzle of it the following day sudeep
takes Extreme Measures to safeguard his
home from the Relentless fly he installs
insect-proof glass sensors and other
sophisticated gadgets because of this
Bindu is forced to go to his residence
and let Nani in sudeep attempts to touch
her improperly but the fly digs into his
flesh with its modified claws forcing
him to run
out of the Pervert the next day
CDP has a crucial meeting with investors
who are ready to invest in his
forthcoming business however the
sleep-deprived so deep instead starts
blabbering about fly repellent sprays
Nani then sits on one of the investors
heads causing sudeep to accidentally
strike him after the Mayhem the
investors decide to cancel the deal
forcing sudeep and his firm into debt
soon the income tax officers are
notified of all the illicit money that
sudeep had stashed away in his office he
frantically attempts to pull the cash
out so he may send it somewhere else but
his money is burned to ashes by the fly
leaving him nearly bankrupt suddenly CDP
recalls the man he had met at The
Dumping site who had informed him that
his fortune would soon be consumed by
fire he goes looking for him and
discovers that the guy is a black Magic
master known as Tantra the latter
reveals that the killer fly is actually
Nani who has been reincarnated to seek
revenge for his death they then carry
out a right and summon two demonic Birds
to capture Nani however Nani manages to
outsmart and eliminate the birds without
even breaking a sweat suddenly the glass
doors get locked and the house starts
filling up with smoke so deep and the
Magic master are stuck and almost
suffocate but they are saved by adithya
later CDP watches the CCTV footage and
learns that it was none other than Bindu
who let the fly inside the house enraged
he captures her and calls out the fly
having no other options left Nani
reluctantly shows himself with this a
fight breaks out between the two and
Bindu somehow manages to escape as the
fly tries to kill sudeep with a needle
he cunningly uses a magnet and finally
traps him sudeep also finds Bindu and
takes her hostage again after this he
cuts off the helpless fly's wings and
starts laughing maniacally right then
Nani notices that the Cannon's muzzle is
open meaning it can fire again so with
his last strength the fly coats himself
with gunpowder and jumps through the
flame of a burning match and into the
previously loaded Canon this results in
the cannon firing at sudeep which
finally kills him the projectile also
hits a nearby oxygen cylinder and the
whole house explodes and engulfs into
flames when Bindu comes out of her
hiding she frantically searches for Nani
but only manages to find one of his
wings realizing that he is no more she
tearfully places it inside her locket
days later as Bindu is driving to work a
random guy starts teasing her just then
Nani who has been reincarnated once
again appears and attacks the guy with a
needle signaling to the world that he is
back
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching